we are here with the beautiful heather
locklear who i've known most of my life
uh we played mother and daughter when i
was seven and she was 21 in fire starter
and uh
you have this new project called don't
sweat the small stuff the kristin
carlson story
and
i would love for you to talk about this
project and the history of the writer
and his wife that you are playing who
becomes the hero of the story
right well um
i think in the 90s it the don't sweat
the small stuff came out and it sold
like 20 million copy i don't know a
bunch of copies and um
this this chris who i play and her
husband richard were very spiritual
people honestly on a different level and
um
they were such a unique couple together
and they would meditate every morning
together in bed had their coffee and uh
had two two girls and he was they had
started writing books together but she
was doing the mom thing and he was doing
his work anyway so he passes away
and suddenly and suddenly chris has to
become
him
him and her a mother and a father
keeping the brand together
going through such a grieving process
that
she learned like
this is the big stuff
don't sweat the small stuff
let's like live moment to moment and
enjoy every moment
and um
that will might help take care of the
big stuff but at least when the big
stuff comes you'll feel
confident that you will get through it
and um she's such a
like an angel honestly and she's just
full of wisdom full of spirituality and
um there are so many synchronicities
between the two of us and between her
and her husband
and um anyway with her two daughters the
strength that she had to raise those two
to keep it together to keep the brand
going and she is still today
um and so with her her book this book
it's it's
such a
journey through what she went to through
when she heard he passed and until you
know a couple a couple years after of
her life and how
she had to accept
and move forward you can either sit back
and
feel bad or you have to you have to move
forward and that will get you out so
she's just an amazing human being and
it's really the story of these three
girls women woman two girls and how um
they stick together and get through
this tragic thing that he was only 45
years old when he died and then she
found like letters uh she had all these
love letters of his she um well first
when she came back all of there was
things in the house that he had written
down like don't forget the dog medicine
don't forget that this don't for this is
what happens on wednesday and thursday
like he had known somehow
that he was slowing down i don't know so
these were she'd find him in books but
then he had written on her um on their
18th wedding anniversary he gave her
this
like semi book and so
she's
looking at this and he's like if i had
my life to live over again i wouldn't
change a thing
chris you are the loved one it was
almost like a goodbye
and he passed three years later
and so um
you know and this is also a book it's
one hour to live one hour to love yeah
and um
so it was it's also incredible you know
for anyone who's going through loss or
divorce or a pet going or losing a job
it's pretty amazing i
i appreciate people who go out there and
say
love it's okay
live as if you have no fears or there
may not be a luxury of time
these are profound
things to me and i parent that way too i
i parent very lovingly you are so right
my daughter i would um i used to be
afraid of saying goodbye and hugging
people and my girlfriend said why don't
you hug me so then i hug everyone the
guy who's taking out my groceries that
they don't do that anymore but i'd hug
him i'm sewing okay gotta get over this
you know shyness and my daughter
says i love you when she hangs up to
anyone
i love you when you're going when she
leaves she loves she's like i think you
know she's afraid that if she doesn't
say that you know how guilty she would
feel if something happened to anyone but
she taught me that and so i love you
drew so i love you too i do
and i was so excited to see you today
and reconnect and speaking of
reconnecting and love may i ask you
about
reconnecting with your high school
sweetheart
no no i'm kidding of course you can
yeah you met this man in high school so
i suppose he was a young man or a boy at
that he was 15. first of all
when you guys were making out could
anyone tell you apart
i are you no
here's the thing
he was he's better looking he's cuter
than me i'm like ugh and then my thought
is i'm like no i i don't think they knew
i mean you look like two halves that
make the perfect hole here or go to the
hilarious stylist i it's just perfect
i'm i didn't realize he actually did his
hair but he obviously did his hair he
didn't say it didn't just go like that i
mean you worked as hard as on his hair
than i as i worked on mine just saying
exactly exactly i love it i love it it's
so meant to be and then you reconnected
years later 40 years later
is there a 40. it's older than you 40
years later no i'm 26.
having been a mother daughter with you i
am so excited for this new uh film to
come out i think the whole
subject is really gonna speak to people
and um
i have loved cheering you on since i was
seven i will continue to do so for my
entire life
and
thank you for all the good amazing
things that you have brought into this
world thank you and vice versa
thank you thank you thank you thank you
heather's new movie don't sweat the
small stuff the kristen carlson story
premieres tomorrow on lifetime
[Music]
you